y
[Música]
muyahidín el tirón queridos
telespectadores bienvenidos a la
entrevista de france 24 hay mucho
misterio en torno a la pandemia que está
matando a millones de personas alrededor
del mundo de según esta pregunta sobre
la eficacia de las vacunas en el mercado
y algunos sospechan que se trata de una
conspiración en contra de la humanidad
para arrojar luz sobre el asunto hoy le
doy la bienvenida al profesor anthony
fauci de maryland el epidemiólogo más
destacado del mundo para hablar sobre
este tema
bienvenido doctor espero que acepte unas
preguntas que pueden parecerle odias a
usted pero como yo no soy doctora me
gustaría entender mejor el asunto bilbao
ha habido anaheim
muy bien
de usted que uno de los primeros en
haber sido vacunado en cómo fue eso sí
acá
si la experiencia fue más bien benigna
como son la mayoría de las vacunas se
siente un leve dolor en el brazo en el
lugar donde entró la aguja de la vacuna
pero después de eso 24 horas después no
hubo ningún síntoma y yo estaba bien no
tuve nada negativo todo estaba
perfectamente bien
algunas personas temen posibles efectos
secundarios e incluso hay algunos que
cuestionan las vacunas y que le diría a
esas personas
bueno tenemos una experiencia
considerable con el ensayo el ensayo de
moderna fue con 30.000 individuos el
ensayo de facer fue con 44 mil
individuos no hubo efectos secundarios
severos los típicos efectos que ocurren
son después de la segunda dosis hay un
grado de dolor muscular tal vez un poco
de fatiga
posiblemente una fiebre pero eso no dura
más de 24 horas lo fundamental es que
tenemos un buen historial hasta el
momento algunas personas han tenido
reacciones alérgicas de las más de 5
millones de vacunas que se han
administrado hasta ahora en eeuu ha
habido 21 reacciones alérgicas
las dos dosis de la vacuna deben ser
administradas dentro de un período de
tiempo específico qué ocurre si una
persona se contagia de coronavirus antes
de recibir la segunda dosis ahora seria
eso podría pasar porque aunque hay
alguna protección con la primera dosis
si se quiere obtener una protección
óptima es necesario tener las dos dosis
entonces es concebible que alguien se
contagie después de recibir la primera
dosis pero es poco probable
qué nos puede decir sobre la mutación
del virus sour
bueno está circulando una mutación en el
reino unido- y hay otro grupo de
mutaciones circulando en sudáfrica al
parecer hace que el virus sea más
transmisible
es decir se propaga con más facilidad de
persona a persona pero no parece que
haya ningún efecto en la virulencia del
virus es decir no parece que enferme más
a las personas o que cause más muertes
pero si se propaga con más facilidad
la mutación ocurrió en los laboratorios
en los laboratorios no ocurrió afuera en
la circulación del virus entre la
comunidad
le causa los mismos síntomas que la
primera variante una ladilla al mar
si no enferma más a las personas solo se
propaga un poco más fácil que el
coronavirus normal
cuánto tiempo dura la edad después de
recibir la vacuna
no está claro cuánto dura la inmunidad
dura al menos varios meses y tal vez más
tiempo la razón por la que no sabemos la
respuesta a la pregunta es porque hemos
estado haciendo esto por un periodo de
tiempo relativamente corto pero dura al
menos varios meses y ojalá mucho más que
eso
recibir la vacuna realmente nos protege
el coronavirus y nos permitirá dejar de
utilizar mascarillas no es importante
seguir utilizando las mascarillas porque
aunque la vacuna protege contra la
enfermedad clínica no necesariamente
previene que alguien se contagie sin
tener síntomas es concebible que alguien
se contagie pero que no tenga ningún
síntoma esa es una de las razones por
las cuales hay que seguir utilizando una
mascarilla también porque hay mucho
virus en la comunidad y hasta que la
mayor parte de la comunidad no esté
vacunada es importante que todo el mundo
siga utilizando una mascarilla
cuál es el punto de recibir la vacuna si
debemos utilizando mascarillas y seguir
teniendo miedo de las otras personas
no eso no se debería confundir uno puede
protegerse a sí mismo de la enfermedad
clínica y de la enfermedad seria
utilizar una mascarilla ayuda a proteger
al resto de la comunidad porque es
posible que uno esté contagiado sin
estar enfermo pero de todas maneras se
tiene el virus en la nasofaringe lo cual
significa que se puede propagar entonces
el objetivo de utilizar una mascarilla
no es solo protegerse a uno mismo sino
proteger a otras personas
la materia no tiene algún tipo de
impacto en el adn de las personas
mayores
no no afecta al adn humano de ninguna
manera esto es una percepción errónea y
es incorrecto
se puede recibir la vacuna si se tienen
síntomas
no si la persona se siente enferma
debería esperar hasta sentirse mejor
antes de recibir la vacuna y si se
siente enfermo debería esperar y recibir
la vacuna cuando se sienta normal
al hay que realizarse una prueba pcr
antes de la vacunación
no no es necesario realizarse una prueba
pcr antes de la vacunación
si alguien ya ha tenido coronavirus de
todas maneras debería recibir la vacuna
si si una persona estuvo previamente
contagiada debería hacerse vacunar
porque no se sabe cuánto tiempo dura la
protección después del contagio
es posible vacunarse contra la gripe y
el comida al mismo tiempo por una final
salvaje
sería preferible administrarlo un poco
diferente tal vez más o menos con una
semana de diferencia no exactamente al
mismo tiempo
a las mujeres embarazadas pueden recibir
la vacuna
y si pueden pero todavía no hemos hecho
un ensayo clínico para probar que es
seguro y efectivo deberían consultar con
su médico familiar para preguntarle si
es prudente hacerlo pero los ensayos
para determinar la seguridad y la
eficacia en las mujeres embarazadas
todavía no se han realizado
si una mujer embarazada se contagia el
feto también lo tiene
no no necesariamente aunque el virus ha
tenido malos efectos en las mujeres
embarazadas en general no hay una gran
preocupación por el bebé
qué ocurre con las personas que tienen
enfermedades crónicas y también pueden
recibir esta vacuna
si las personas con enfermedades
crónicas deberían vacunarse en
particular porque la severidad de la
enfermedad es peor en individuos que
tienen una condición preexistente
entonces es importante que las personas
con condiciones preexistentes reciban la
vacuna
el coronavirus varía de un país a otro
por lo general es el mismo hay ciertas
mutaciones en un lugar frente a otro
pero en general los virus son los mismos
entre los países y una mutación en el
reino unido y en sudáfrica que es un
poco diferente de las otras pero en
general los virus son los mismos
las características físicas de una
persona como su tipo de sangre tienen
alguna diferencia en los efectos de la
enfermedad y un leve aumento en la
susceptibilidad si se tiene un tipo de
sangre o frente a un tipo de sangre
el tipo de sangre es más propenso a
contagiarse mientras que el tipo de
sangre es menos propenso
y los niños pueden transmitir el
contagio
los niños pueden transmitir el contagio
tal vez un poco menos que los adultos
pero pueden transmitir el contagio
aunque la fuerza del virus podría
disminuir con el tiempo ur y albox
si es concebible que la fuerza del virus
disminuya pero todavía no lo sabemos
cuando acabará la pesadilla el
coronavirus si las personas reciben la
vacuna a nivel mundial y obtenemos una
buena aceptación de la vacuna entre la
mayoría de las personas en el mundo
podríamos empezar a regresar a la
normalidad hacia finales de 2021 hacia
el tercer trimestre el otoño de 2021
y no quiero hacerle sentir que está
siendo interrogado pero tengo que
hacerle una pregunta que muchos están
haciendo es un poco personal
yo sí
cuál es la naturaleza de su disputa
contra nosotros y cuál es la naturaleza
de su relación con byd en que le pidió
se uniera su equipo el chef a cobijar y
tejido
y mire al equipo de byd en apenas se
haya posicionado el 20 de enero mi
relación con el presidente de trump es
buena es una buena relación tenemos
algunos desacuerdos pero en general es
una buena relación
doctor muchas gracias doctor fauci por
aceptar nuestra invitación gracias a
ustedes en casa quédense con nosotros en
france 24
[Música]